[Music]
[Laughter]
another episode and a shell
yeah yeah chillin another episode of the
show Sony trim and a boat first poppin
guess ya just popped in yeah in the
neighborhood yeah you live that's far
too far from here yeah and then I ate
you up you like well can I come through
I said here's where we are
I beat in five minutes damn that's the
kind of commitment you get Tony was
hyped john jon hamm you are legit one of
my hero that's very kind of you to say
thank you um out of all the TV
personalities with lunchmeat last names
Jon Hamm is the one that I'm most that
character Don Draper is the most that
I've ever wanted to be careful what you
wish for
well thank you that's very nice of you
to say I appreciate that and it's good
to be here buddy I mean we've seen a lot
of each other last few days you holdin
up I'm good nice break from it we did
the press junket in here in LA
Dallas in Miami and it it's a grind and
it's a grind and it's my first time
experiencing it to that extent but what
made it bearable was that each city's
journalist and a different feel yeah
Miami especially yeah Miami
it was live Spanish like the
spanish-language broadcasters have a
different approach toward press yeah
it's a it's a whole thing
also in Miami we went on these shows at
a Spanish line
so they put here we air we try to
translate so you're gonna live
translation getting live translations
you answer in English and then they
translate and then they ask you
something in Spanish do you get the
translation in your ear so that kind of
rhythmically is a bit weird
well how long's the lag on that it's
basically instant like he's translating
it live but you're trying to it's weird
cuz you're not sure to listen to look at
right you're not sure where to go and
it's kind of you're trying to listen to
two things at once and yeah only one ear
know what they're crazy
no it's not yeah we need to hear maybe
while the 15-piece mariachi band is
playing
Chicago mariachi boy it was bonkers and
it was like 7 o'clock in the morning so
you're just like what is right why was
there a hole yeah and it's like wake up
wake up America that'll get you up focus
but also it's like it's just there's no
cynicism that was when I what I really
liked about it like they they they were
all just like thanks for being here like
this but we're gonna have some fun and
you're like oh alright like it's not
this like we know you've done this all
before so and I'm you're gonna like me
you know just get through it with us
there's like to have a good time and you
like 40 violins going off like yeah who
doesn't
playing games and stuff or was just
placing musical chairs musical chairs I
think that was it on that one yeah it
was one thing that threw me off about
no-shows is that each time afterwards
there were 20 people with cell phones
also filming because everybody wants
like the version of it for whatever
social media however they do it but ya
know it was the the ancillary part of it
like the other part of it seems to
gotten so much bigger yeah but it just
increases the like effect of the grind
we were just like all right we got to do
this then we got it four more
dislike was but doing it with a group it
was way better with a group that's for
sure and we have a good group I mean a
funny guys so like that was also
recognizing the absurdity of it was was
was kind of fun and um itself I thought
did you have to do that type of press
for a baby driver it oh I missed all of
that cuz we're shooting oh so there they
went on like a world tour yeah
which I've never done so they were in
Asia and you know Malaysia in Australia
and Europe and all this other stuff and
I don't have to do any of that because I
was down there shooting baby driver was
released while we were filming - yeah in
Atlanta and we had a night shoot yeah I
went to see baby driver during the day
and your character was insane somebody
watched a movie in theaters before and
it was kind of like yo Stu's crazy but
you saw Baby Jogger baby drive her baby
you trying to pull it up you didn't see
okay okay
maybe I missed that one yeah it was
you'll see it on plane yeah wait what is
it about it's like a cops and robbers
yeah okay murder all right okay yeah no
I was it was a fun one it was certainly
fun to shoot because you know we we used
Atlanta for Atlanta yeah and there were
all these local like weirdos like you
know the ATL twins those crazy yeah and
they're just like Atlanta fixtures I
don't know I've never but like I feel
like like that that guy yeah but and
then like I think big boy from Outkast
is in it and one of the scenes Killa
might come on in it yeah like there's
there's a lot of a lot of cool like kind
of Atlanta named drops which is really
nice yes
killer and did you what did you what do
you do to get into an evil place it
doesn't take that much you know
something something somebody did
something that's gonna annoy you in this
career every day so just think about
that yeah I saw actually went I didn't
go to see my movie because I'd seen it
before and that's weird but I
I was ed and I went to see kumail's
movie big sick yeah at that little
theater and I didn't realize the baby
was playing there and we were waiting
outside the movie for Ed's mom who went
with us we would like her a couple 14
year olds and and I'm waiting there and
waiting there we're waiting for his mama
wait for his mama she's kind of taking a
long time and then the movie lets out
and it looks like I'm waiting around for
people who say i did that with daddy's
home once you go in i watched it I
watched like with the comedy you kind of
want to see yeah you know see with it
with it I want to see ours like I wanna
see tag with a with a real audience not
a premiere on it's not a hand-picked
audience or whatever I mean you did
recently right I mean it was I was
excited to see it cuz you get is nerve
wrecking thing where you've been you
know you do something for a few months
and then it you kind of detach from it
well it's certainly not like doing
stand-up or yeah the response is
immediate anything live you like alright
that worked if it didn't work or it
could work you know you can figure it
out or work on it or make it better or
whatever this is like good luck go for
it who knows what they picked those I've
done stuff where
oh yeah we had some we went on some
crazy runs and tangents cuz it was so
improvi they're like what they're never
gonna use any of them we were just
literally wasting time and they use
something they don't you got you got
some improv background at all not really
not really like I've done it with kind
of with friends a lot but the actual
likes you know people that study like
McBrayer is a good buddy of mine he's
been doing it for 30 years I mean it's
just like he's he's so well-versed in
that language and so loose and so easy
where I'm still like a like a you know
dog that's learning how to walk in that
world but it's also you have fun yeah
yeah I mean also like if you're well
known at all you get a lot of leeway
yeah I mean people are like are he's
trying like whatever yeah break yeah
because because your role is you know
every you know everybody knew you as Don
Draper and then you just pop up doing
funny [ __ ] and I mean like this is way
funnier because it is Jon Hamm yeah you
know I mean the expectation is certainly
not there to be to be funny or goofy or
take the piss out of yourself or
whatever and that was like that was all
Lorne Michaels and Tina like they were
the ones that you know I remember did I
meet you the first step first time
oh nice to know first a second one
however girl
I think 9010 remember the first one but
I did like three like in two years he
said it was crazy but I remember Tina
said she called Lauren was like that got
funny and was like worlder you know the
table went well you know loosen and then
I got down to the to my dressing room
after table and you know picking the
show or whatever got down the dresser
and the phone rang and my professor was
like what what's going on who's calling
me at SNL and it was Robert Carlock from
30 rock games like you want to come do
the show yeah of course I did that easy
it's not that easy yes yeah so you
posted it now four three three I've been
on it like I've done walk-ons on
everybody else's shows like wigs last
show I did the cold open I was on Lena
Dunham show I was on Lindsay Lohan show
I was like a plant in the audience and
they're like don't worry Lindsay if it
all goes sideways we have a backup and
I'm like yeah it was literally a
one-second cut away but yeah it's it's
uh it's it's nice to be kind of
considered part of that group right
because it's it's it's such a specific
group and people I really like you know
I went out my first time hosting was
polar and my or still there oh that was
so so then you know and that was I think
their last year basically and uh and
then Kristen and Bill and and Samberg
and the Lonely Island guys we're just
getting ready to kind of take over the
show and kina Mo's Erica's Keenan's
always been there it seems like someone
is crazy they did a bit represent in the
family few with him as Steve Harvey oh
no it was like yeah what's what's the
second act like anything any big break a
broke character yeah you know sometimes
you do that you do the same thing
forever right yeah that's cool that's
cool right I think he like looked into
the camera - yeah he's an all-star
though man that guy's great he's been
doing sketch comedy longer than he
hasn't been doing absolutely that's
insane to think about it was a kid on
kion Kenan & Kel
like a legit kid eight or nine yeah
that's crazy that's the people bit of a
newness since then like that's been
doing it since they were kids that's
bonkers I don't understand that haven't
like having a childhood in this industry
I I don't know if I would have handled
that well
cuz I don't handle it that well as a
brony when you first started getting I
mean I moved out to LA when I was 25 in
19 or 24 1995 yeah so yeah like I've
been I was acting in college and stuff
but you know you don't make any money
doing it and to make money edit either
movie New York Chicago or LA really and
I had people out here so I was like I'm
gonna move out how like the weather you
know I don't mind driving and I moved
out here in 95 I didn't work I didn't
get my first job as an actor till 1998
yeah what was that it was this it was
the the DL Hughley
I was I was like the crazy white
neighbor on the hughley's for five lines
you know that was my first literally
think time I got paid I mean I wasn't
even like the main never like I was the
other neighbor and that the storyline
was they all the guys wanted to buy
crazy [ __ ] and their wives wouldn't let
him so I let everybody use my garage to
keep all their crazy [ __ ] it was so
weird remember that so long ago no I
never I never was my roommate was a
substitute teacher and he was always
trying to get me to to get into that
pool yeah but I wanted to keep my days
free just in case I got an audition or
something going on so we started off as
a school teacher right when I got out of
college I started boxing in wait tables
and then I was making ok money but I
wanted to really get into that good
money like teaching which you know I
think I got paid $24,000 a year for one
year which was more money than I've ever
seen in my life so I was like this is
good good job
but I only did it for one year and I
went back to my old high school because
I knew everything kind of worked and
where everything was so it was it was a
great job one of my students is Ellie
Kemper who's on unbreakable Kimmy
Schmidt oh yeah
like and we were in bridesmaids together
so that was weird that's it I taught her
yeah it's so weird and she's you know I
know her family like I knew her mom and
dad I had like PTA meetings with mom and
dad and stuff it's like ok good for you
you raised it you raised a cool kid
she knows how to sail she really
she's funny obviously but she knows she
really sails the joke of who's
performing a crossover oh yeah yeah I
mean it's the cop that comedy is so
dense like that's so dense did you write
on 30 rock dude yeah
the the jokes per page or is such a high
number yeah that it demands that kind of
commitment like Tina was very good at it
too obviously it was racy everybody on
that show but uh but Elly's got
definitely has that delivery down yeah
yeah Jake said the same thing about what
to keep his time free just in case the
case I mean that's my thing was like
when I first got out here I got a job I
lived in Silver Lake and I got a job in
Venice and that was the only job I could
find I was like whatever I'll just drive
I don't want to driving that's fine and
I've rapidly realized that that was not
a very efficient way to like spend time
but I had friends that lived in Venice
so if we ever went out partying I just
crash on your couch or whatever and then
that would turn into like basically me
staying there for like three days
hanging out on the beach you know
playing volleyball whatever and like
because I got at work so why am I gonna
drive all the way back so we're looking
then all the way back you know to Venice
and like two months in I was like I'm
not doing anything
I'm literally like it's it's it's
literally just I'm getting really good
at volleyball and like I've got a great
tan but other than that like I'm not
paying attention to the reason that I
moved out here in the shape there was
definitely I'm sure that helped positive
energy coming from it but yes and not
career-wise it was not a thing so did
you you meet the actual tag guys sorry
[Laughter]
it will take a couple of days that but
are you gonna are you gonna Toronto New
York - I'm going to New York
but that's two more days of it yeah yeah
it was a five questions and they're
they're burnt in my brain
what's the five questions five quest did
you ever meet the guys the real guys
meets real tank guys what did you think
when you read the script what do you
think what you read the screen still
play tag do you still have friends who
you talk to Miranda broke his arm
Jeremy Ranbir's arm so that was it there
was literally literally those five every
time for yeah at least and he's kind of
like you you released he got paired with
Jake so you had you guys could just go
crazy
I was with Eden Renner and those are two
wildly different energies to say the
least
he was saying earlier that like they
were doing an interview and they were
there like that they had in the
background
do you like disassociate we should do
the next one you should bring the
therapy and the next time something like
that happens what are you thinking if
you like this is what I was thinking
it
Hey
got a new name for you in this podcast
you know John ham hey John can you can
you spit bars at all I'm assuming that
means have some sort of flow in the rap
game
yeah that should give you an idea about
how idiot - it's funny you say John Jam
because my full name is Jonathan Daniel
ham and in when I was in grade school I
went to a very very white suburban grade
school until fourth grade and my mom
passed away I had to move him my dad who
lived in the black neighborhood and so I
went to a pretty much all black fifth
and sixth grade and this was in the
early 80s okay
so hip hop was starting but it wasn't
really the thing was mostly R&B and like
it was yeah there was that and and I
think was right around the time George
Clinton put out atomic dog so that was
like the soundtrack to my fifth and
sixth grade and like the first time you
kind of go to dances followed my fashion
did not I was I was very much out of
place but whatever everyone's out of
place when they're that age but so there
was this book that was going around you
had to write out like answer all the
questions whatever like slam book
whatever and I was like who's doing this
I don't know I'm new here and they're
like what would your like DJ named rap
name be it was and I wrote down Johnson
Jack Johnson
but that was so that was the beginnings
of my hip-hop career right there and the
resurgence 2.0 you said R&B right yeah
so were you singing at all at least no
no I can't I can't
it's not mine I could see like Jah Jah
Jam as like shirtless and just yeah some
R&B vibes that was my jam when I was was
any kind of video game the arcade what
was your favorite arcade of all time man
those days those were the days of like
Missile Command and defender pac-man
I'll tell you what my one of my really
favorite ones would neither what you're
both probably too young to remember this
but there was like a table game remember
those things they had in bars sometimes
there was like you sit across from
somebody on a low table you could both
be the play against each other whatever
and they had a little X's and O's
football game they had a it was a
trackball thing and you would play
football basically and there was a my
dad and I used to go watch Monday Night
Football at this one place and they had
it my dad was had no nothing nothing to
do with video games so I basically beat
him it was really funny would watch mine
in a football the other that was my
favorite video game no idea what was
called no idea was called alright that
in Donkey Kong I did like Donkey yeah
well Donkey Kong's a classic remember
paper football yeah that was great yeah
was it was it all you do is shoot a
[ __ ] dude like push it back and forth
back and forth telegrams yeah and then
if you didn't make the other guy to do
it and then you could kick it and they
would have to make the I thought it was
just this and flicking it you know it
was some
some offense - it wasn't the kicking
game was not purely special-teams you
play you play baseball yeah in high
school yeah yeah yeah I still play you
still play yeah I'm a men's league here
in LA what's your position
for space now I used to be a catcher Oh
No I'm old means you're a stud I can
play I can play a little bit yeah it's
as far as you get older can you keep the
skills sharp because I don't play
everyday at all
so can you hit a 90 mile per hour no
absolutely not
there is no I could start swinging today
yeah that's and then you pitch it
tomorrow and I'd still miss that's like
it that I that seems impossible it is I
mean that the there that's how good
those guys are yeah that's crazy
that's insane we're not at that level
there's there's nothing like that
happened yeah you ever see that uh
documentary fastball no does thank God I
see that it's just it's literally a
documentary of oh wait I've heard about
this yeah oh you gotta see it it's crazy
they break down they break down the
fastball like in the mouse on Netflix I
gotta watch I'm not sure if it's on
Netflix but you know how like baseball
players swear that there is a rising
fastball they will they completely
disprove the bunk that yeah yeah because
physically it's impossible but these
hitters they in their testimony looks
like yeah their testimonies in the all
of them are all across the board like if
you don't believe in the rising fast
balls because you've never been that
batter's box before well that's why
those guys like when they miss they're
genuinely like dumbfounded like how did
I miss that ball it must have done
something magical yeah that's great
that's baseball such a fascinating sport
it's so fun I mean it's literally like
the only reason I do it is because I've
all those guys are my friends
it's fun and it's a way to get outside
and and do something which makes you
feel better how many times have you
thrown out a first pitch that again once
just once yeah yeah then st. Louis yeah
they had a bobblehead day and they gave
out bobbleheads of me yeah and I got my
first pitch yes
yeah it was really fun how was it first
[ __ ] fine I just lobbed it in Ozzie
Smith caught it it was nothing
you know I'm too crazy I didn't go crazy
on I was like there's no way in st.
Louis mm-hmm why I say Louis what's real
from oh okay yeah sorry and I grew up
like basically idolizing Ozzie Smith
so he's like cause his ball can give me
a hug I was like there's no way this is
happening it was really cool
nice my family was there had some
friends there was like that's awesome
throughout Chicago South Side south side
when they were good when they were good
like mm okay we're bad
yeah they were all right I actually only
got to throw the first pitch because
somebody who worked at the ticketing
office was a fan I wasn't famous enough
to be thrown first pitch I think I just
finished up right now 30 rock and I had
I didn't even have a special yeah had a
decent draw in Chicago I was doing a
couple weeks at the comedy club but as
far as general people it wasn't
awareness when I was introduced
well people also don't realize it's like
way before the game starts to like they
got the dog show out there and they got
the little kids can run around the bases
and whatever and so there's the stands
are like a quarter full anyway it's not
the World Series should get like nine
people like your family clapping for you
and that's it actually two other people
throughout first pitches really point my
first baseman definitely sometimes do
that work we practiced that we had Moses
it was was it 50 cent Mindy see ya like
sideways right but I wanted he did it on
purpose no it's you cuz just getting it
over the meadow that doesn't get you
clicks no I don't think he did I think
he was trying I think he was trying hard
and failed don't worry when he does it
before the Cubs game usually does
something goofy throws it in the stands
or whatever you know I looked on first
base you can hit my dad anybody over
there
just milking it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the picture too is hilarious did you get
dressed up in gear they gave me a Jersey
yeah had a Jersey and a hat on some
jeans it was uh it was exciting
wait what didn't you get invited to do
the Cubs this year yeah well I did but I
postponed it cuz it was a it was a weird
week probably also overtake and nobody
was out there with a Mike and the ball
then maybe hey look listen guys what's
up Chicago anyway I got some things to
say before before I'm gonna throw this
ball out it's a mad Midway oh this is
this is different now probably the first
season first night at the end of the
first season because by the end of that
the we had gotten nominated for all
these crazy awards and whatnot and won a
bunch of them and then like I think was
shot from like June to September or
something and we had won a bunch of
Emmys while we were shooting the second
season and it was crazy we were just we
were all kind of like what now and it
just kept continuing and we were just
blown away that that show changed again
I'll tell you one thing's for sure when
I started watching that show around
second or the third season I started
changing my style up bro
there was a big big effect I'm not
dressing better always washing my hands
what happened since then I got fresh and
clean well it was like it was cuz it it
people hadn't seen that look yeah yeah
it was really it was a real fresh kind
of take on
a time that people thought when people
thought of the 60s before and they
thought of hippies and and whatever and
you know all that stuff so the fresh on
the other yeah I liked the more
establishment side of it people didn't
really think of until our show and then
it kind of became this weird cultural
touchstone I guess and like just the
detailing of everything like them the
the costumes to the you know to the set
design like it was just to the T ya know
it was a great show to work on man I
have blast it was a blast but it was
like it was a decade in my life - yeah
hey you know from I'm 35 I think when I
started it
the theme song have you ever actually
listened to the lyrical version no I
didn't know there was one it was like
something super upbeat that's a but this
uh underground rapper named a sea alone
that me and this guy grew up on
listening uh-huh and the beat is by a
legendary hip-hop producer named rjd2
right and it's off of his album and they
just took the instrumental and turned it
into the things ya know it's a I think
was called a beautiful mind yes yes and
I remember when they first played it for
us and they showed the the opening
sequence because you know we're probably
in episode 10 of the first season what
before they had it all put together and
they're like okay we have the we have
the the opening credits bro ah let's see
it we don't hope you know the main
writer and the executive producer come
from The Sopranos as I love those
Sopranos opening credits like if we get
a cool opening sequence it'll be great
people will want to watch it they won't
skip through it on TiVo and they showed
it to us I was like whoa that's really
cool yeah it was really really really
well done and yeah but I never heard the
lyric listen to it Anna
did you ever hear it was it Hannibal you
brought that to my attention that the
spoof did a song it was on an SNL
episode right
let me thin ties cigarettes Sesame
Street what yeah
they had like a bunch of guys in suits
and hair and whatever and I was like
guys this is appropriate
a lot of borderline sexual assaults and
like weird like not so border like okay
abusive did you catch flack as Jon Hamm
for playing that character
I mean people yeah people people
conflate the two all the time but uh but
I was you know again that's why I did a
lot of the comedy stuff that I do it's
just like oh yeah lighten it up put that
aside guys so that the comedy stuffs way
more Who I am
you know did you were you doing were you
dabbling with comedy before no but I I
knew a lot of when I first came out here
95 like that was when old Largo Monday
nights at Largo that was the that was
the big show it was kind of like who
knows who was gonna be there but Zach
Galifianakis Sarah Silverman Paul F
Tompkins Patton Oswalt Doug Benson
Demetri Martin s other Tenacious D it
was like it was just a bunch of crazy
talented people and it was five bucks
so that was my that basically was you
know all the money all the money I could
really spend and then I got to I just
kept going there and and had a bunch of
friends that all kind of knew everybody
and we all became this weird you know
kind of friend group and I got to know
flan II who runs the runs that joint and
in you know and you just got funny off
from osmosis I guess yeah something like
that but cuz you be I mean when you when
you pop up you're [ __ ] hilarious well
I was always stuff that I'd like I was
listening to you know that stuff when I
I was raised by a single mom so then the
era before internet if you wanted to
listen to comedy you had to go get a
record like an LP record and then they
had him at the library and it was you
know wildly inappropriate for a
seven-year-old but I was like I don't
care I'm gonna go I'm gonna go to the
library and check out like Richard Pryor
records and George Carlin and Cheech and
Chong and all this but even like Bob
Newhart and and Nichols and May and it's
all this stuff that was was available
and
was a wide very wide you know disparate
group of people but that was just always
how I i'd like to entertain myself was
like laughs yeah did you go to school
spouting out Richard Pryor everything so
your classmates yeah I think my mom
there's a there's a there's a I won't
say the the word but there's a title of
a Richard Pryor record called
Bicentennial and and my mom found that
it and in the in the stack of records
that I was returning and she's like
really like it's really funny I should
because great-great my sister took me to
go see live on the Sunset Strip and we
made it about eight minutes into that
and she was like no yeah nope turned me
right around was he's really sick stay
with it it's funny but what does she
think it was gonna be she just wanted
something to do with like her little
brother just said you just put himself
out he's probably fine Yeah right yeah
who you ever a fan of Dice Clay I mean
he had his moment in time his stuff was
a little broad for me like I mean there
was a time in high school when everybody
was quoting that guy and I was I just
thought it was like Dennis Miller had
the best impression of his like why you
worried about this guy's Fonzie with
Tourette syndrome that's about right
that seems about right
but he could fill up arena in 1988
that's for sure 88 that's crazy what
just that scale he saw that massacre
garden like four days in a row yeah he
was like the hottest comic of his time
of that time yeah like coming from my
perspective perspective I was a child
when I first and taking nursery rhymes
yeah like three blind mice yeah yeah
what a [ __ ] it go like that's
hilarious to me what I'm again of course
you know yeah but I mean there's it's
weird there's always there's it seems
like every generation has a guy like
that that's out sighs popularity for the
for the material you know what I mean
like I remember what
when I came out here probably bout five
or ten years after I've been out here
five years maybe and I sort of didn't
know like the kind of alt comedy scene
and whatnot and really liked that it was
a smart it was funny it was kind of
oblique way into the into the joke and
then everybody was all mad because Dane
Cook was like selling out arenas yeah
and he was he was one of the first guys
to like really get into like social
media and it's infinity he was good and
and and that became a thing and there
was all this kind of resentment and
bitterness toward him and I was like all
right well who cares like hey you know
let the guy make his money like he's not
taking anything away from you he's
definitely not taking your audience away
yeah like and and I just think people
got all twisted on that but how long ago
left left - kind of like worrying about
other people's careers and like just
worry about your own yeah who do you
think that guy is right now right now
yeah I mean you can look like Kevin Hart
I mean he's like he's he's a multi you
know multi - it at this point he's like
a crazy brand yeah football stadium the
differences with Kevin and Dane when
they both kind of utilized the internet
and getting their fans information and
marketing directly to them and grow in
the audience with dice in the 80s there
was none of that
well that was Stern has caught on he
went oh how start you know start I mean
that was a place where you could really
break lay the stern show cuz it reached
so many people one of the first like
syndicated you know Drivetime shows and
he has such a big audience and it's such
a crazy wide-ranging audience - like
it's and he was really Stern was really
popular back then and because there was
no you know there was no internet there
was no social media it was like radio
and cable and that's it yeah just sell
out arenas then no internet just you
heard about this guy
yeah Steve Martin used to do in the 70s
I mean like he had he would sell out you
know Dodger Stadium it's like it's why
he's got he wears hearing aids now cuz
he's keys he would play in front of you
know that stacks of amplifiers and do
and do comedy and just kidding
his ears blown out basically every night
in front of 50,000 people
he was I loved I'd still like Steve
Martin he's he's he's really funny to me
that was one of the first times I was
like oh I get what you're doing like
you're doing hacky jokes but kind of
make fun making fun of them at the same
way I was like I get I get that
that guy's smart his book was great does
it stand it up Oh what was it uh
something like that yeah born born
standing up maybe boy standing yeah have
you guys watched that uh that CNN series
of the history of comedy it's like an
eight part series I think I've seen a
couple of them oh it's awesome yeah it's
like a real in-depth like yeah I think
I've seen a couple of them though CNN
things are cool like the ones I do about
the decades mm-hmm access is so much
stuff yeah did you know there's a thing
in the CNN office in Atlanta which I got
a C for real one day that is it's a
video cassette tape that says to be
played at the end of the world
in a case of no it's like it's somewhere
yeah it's in a in a file somewhere and
it's like a picture of the White House
and the American so hanging like people
playing like whatever that song was one
of the Titanic national anthem or
something like if the button gets pushed
yeah and they're like well it's you know
sorry to break it to everybody but this
is it then they go they put that yeah
that is dark
[Applause]
I mean but I guess it's good to be
prepared that's great who's the producer
they thought about that tape is it tape
it tape they still have a tape machine
but like you know yes just saying hey if
the world is about the end please don't
run this we're not gonna run this and
then get something what's y'all theory
oh what's on it I just I've seen I've
seen it oh okay
I just don't know if it's on a loop or
not or whatever cuz you know I thought
you had like it hasn't been seen it's
only it can only be played
I read about it once on some some
website somewhere man that is all right
could be prepared excellent gotta let
that you got to let the anchor try to
get to safety to job before you are like
one fascinating thing about Jon Hamm is
he is full of random facts you you bring
something up he'll have something to say
I've always been that way I was like a
little kid we used to get these at
school you used to like sign up for like
flashcar like yeah about dinosaurs about
animals about whatever and I signed up
for all that should not have these
little weird little things and again
there's nothing to do other than that
because there was you know video games
are expensive and there was no internet
and you know the library was a long way
away and so I've to sit there and like
read about world capitals or animals in
Africa or the difference between
Australia and you know whatever it was
you are a thirsty mind I definitely was
or just bored my facts that I I know
where this is random random small
colleges aren't just because of somebody
yeah with a uniform green state yeah
bull degrees they have yeah I went to
University of North Texas and my lesson
did don't right yeah
yeah they blew how do you blow a 52
point line you can't score once is
random 70 point over and you can't cover
that just come on specific random [ __ ]
you remember it is funny like that
though that's the the especially doing
what we kind of do be an entertainment
in straining way you're exposed to a lot
a lot of stuff just a lot of information
and I've always been I've always been
the kind of a learner that just really
listens all the time which is that's
good or not but you know what's the
weird is personal parents type thing
you've done have you probably won I
don't know if it's the weirdest but like
hosting the ESPYs was a weird experience
because I'm not really a host right
but it was I've done a movie for Disney
and it was about sports and they were
like oh this would be good like it'll be
alright and I mean I know I watch sports
I enjoy sports so it wasn't like I was
you know going in without any version of
that but one of my first jobs actually
was a an extra in a commercial for the
ESPYs when Sam Jackson hosted them in
like 1995 1997 or something like that
they flew me to New York and I was like
a extra doing lead extra I guess the
block yeah no I did not first class but
I got flown and and then like flash 20
years later I was hosting the show which
is weird but yeah that was a weird one
because like also doing doing jokes we
had a bunch of the SNL writers like
Kevin Miller Alex Bayes wrote a lot of
the lot of the material for uh for the
show so you had hosted SNL how many
times that one you had all right you had
done all yeah yeah and and so they they
wrote all the material but like doing
material for a bunch of athletes who
were like if it's not about me I don't
care is in that room which is the Nokia
whatever that big room is rough and I'm
not I'm not a comic like I know how to
deliver a joke and you know make
something funny but I'm not
like I don't have like my material that
I can't fall back on I guess I'm not gay
yeah so I just like put my head down
that was just like this is all gonna be
over in an hour and a half I'll be fine
do you ever give weird offers hey this
uh this Sheikh wants to hang out with
you
if I have I have not heard it I've
definitely heard I know some people who
have had those and who have taken up
people on those are million dollars you
want to come hang on my boat and can I
mean alright I guess I mean if remember
that time who was the who's the person
that went to like somebody's birthday
party in like Chechnya or something and
then they got like a real blowback
because they're like oh this dude's a
straight-up monster cycle is so weird
that he has a North Korean story yeah
like clockwork every four to six but I
feel like it was somebody really like
Hilary Swank or something like that like
it was just a weird really like ya know
I didn't know he was evil despot no he
was a genocide I could see like I could
see a Kardashian doing that - yeah kind
of like that when it when the pursuit of
of money is that is the whole deal
you're kind of like you'd find yourself
in situations like that Rea like oh
whoops I didn't think this through quite
all the way even sometimes even if like
the description of the gig I know
there's no chance of me doing it Howie I
asked how much just to see what this
person thinks of me what's going on with
you my family realized we got about
$1,500 in a hotel room
No what what no I mean I get I guess I
get the idea of shooting your shot and
yeah you never ask never know you never
know who's gonna say yes I know but be
reasonable with that [ __ ] like I don't
do weddings like I DJ mm-hmm
but I don't I don't do weddings so
whenever somebody asked me I always give
them like like very over the mark number
sure and if somebody's gonna take you up
on that actually and then you do do
weddings or you do wait so they've taken
me up on it twice but they never
followed up I see you see what I'm
saying they're like yeah yeah sure we
can we can do that and then never
followed up yeah whooping quarter
million dollars do our wedding I mean
that's not even a wedding gig anymore
that's just for a month yeah are you
playing a wet no I plan to change my
life get some wedding to everybody else
but this is my future
what is it what is the weirdest thing
that you've been asked that you've taken
up somebody knocking up like the
weirdest gig because I know you'd like
to think out of the box you know try
different [ __ ] in and maybe even be a
little uncomfortable west of us what's
the have we done any terrible ones
recently we did that weird like that jmf
one or something in Chicago remember
that one how did you is that yeah it was
like some fundraiser for like Jewish
kids not to sound anti-semitic but it
was a weird gig it's just what people
are eating what is a bank is like is
silverware on plates oh I did this it
was a
a sports thing was mpa Awards or
something and I prepared all these jokes
it wasn't it was it was in Century City
in LA and I forget this is already well
I got an on place yeah Westbrook was
there a few other players were there and
I was supposed to do a a set and they
kind of just brought me on with no it
wasn't a good intro just like go out
there and everybody was still just
talking and I did a handful of my jokes
and you know this is going sour awfully
like nobody well it was one of those
things nobody a handful of people are
listening but they can't really listen
cuz everybody's talking yeah you gotta
like do show like that you know whip
around or did you just know it was just
one of those left to build it angrily
you got paid though right I don't think
I don't know if that was a paid gig I
think I did that was one that I did
thinking if I kill this I'll be the once
the connections gig I'll do it for free
and I did that [ __ ] I was like huh
should have passed on that I'm telling
you doing jokes to a roomful of athletes
is hard yeah is is being that be
especially like in a all-star situation
or whatever when it's all everybody's a
a list elite athletes because they're
all like they've been paying attention
to nobody but themselves for a long time
and that's what you had to do at that
level like you just that's all you know
I went to the Game one of the NBA finals
this year and like both LeBron and Steph
Curry have this otherworldly kind of
charisma
that's just they're like oh they they
know how good they are right and how
good they are is the best and they've
been the best player on every team that
they've ever played on and now they're
the best player on the teams that are
playing for the championship right and
there and they just the way they move
you're just like I'm not telling you
anything you know the TV on and it's
somebody talking
about how though they are yeah all the
time but also like it doesn't matter if
you don't deliver right
LeBron scored 51 in that game and they
lost and Steph I don't know he hit 35 or
something including like a 32 foot jump
shot to end the half to tie it and he
shot it was it was four feet in front of
me he shot it and he just watched it
going and turned around to the audience
and went like yeah whoo I knew it was
going in who are you for goal and stay
at her calves
I think Golden State I like like I mean
it I have insane respect for what LeBron
is doing and has done but I just like
that crazy offense that they run on
Golden State I love watching that it's
like a it's there's so many moving parts
and they all work so well together I'm
really a NBA fan I grew up in st. Louis
we didn't have a NBA team really we had
the st. Louis spirits in the ABA and
then the st. Louis Hawks that moved to
Atlanta in like 77 but I was I was a fan
in like magic and Larry you know back
and forth that was fun to watch in the
Nick Jordan era with like their rivalry
rivalry with like the Knicks and the
Pistons and all that stuff that was
amazing
but yeah the Golden State team I just I
just love watching that offense when
it's clicking you're like how do you
stop you can't stop this see I'm free
I'm for the Cavs just because I want to
see one man beat a whole nother - yeah I
mean and you almost saw it in Game one
yeah Akil it took that team I was
watching him because the nobody could
defend him that's amazing and he back to
Steve somehow Steph Curry was on him
one-on-one and he backed him down so
hard it sounded like a boxer punching a
guy cuz he just kept me was dribbling
backing him down in the lane and his his
shoulder was slammed in this Steph Curry
and moving him back like two feet each
time is that's what it sounded like
sound like somebody punching somebody as
hard as it could it's got our earth
you're on the floor he's got to be yeah
I was kind of like I was in the second
row on the floor so you can hear
everything and then the end was amazing
when everybody got in a fight it was
like this is this this is a good rivalry
how close were you and Jay
Smith debacle happened it was on my side
of the floor I mean it wasn't my my end
of the floor I should say so right now
what was going through your head well I
was like there to lose this game like
the one state's gonna lose this game and
everybody in the arena was tight and
then when he missed the free throw
everybody like kind of exhale because it
was still tied and then they got the
rebound and everybody kind of jumped up
like no yeah all we had to do was one
thing like hit the rebound there were
four seconds left and then he started
dribbling around I'm like what is he
doing that's make sure everybody thought
like what is he doing he just he was
Steve he lost us he lost his place in
the story you know and then it was over
you could tell like that team just
literally deflated after that they were
like we had his back from we had it and
we lost it that's so and then the post
conference was so hilarious when LeBron
just got so mad and grabbed this person
vote the memes and all that [ __ ] when he
just grabbed when he had his little
shorts suits and he grabbed his personal
wrist or tomorrow that's a heart
that's a hard look to to to look hard on
you know a short suit and a little Louis
Vuitton bag or whatever
freedom are there was a comic once it
was like there's certain things that you
cannot look tough doing and like that's
one of them he goes putting on chapstick
like nobody looks tough putting on
chapstick [ __ ] I'm gonna kill
you hold on shorts or do a soup or even
the the pants cut a high up a little bit
you know what I'm saying that's alright
yeah you know what I'm saying well you
ankle yeah the high ankle when you got
you know when you got them uh otherwise
you look like a looked like a Victorian
schoolboy yeah it just it's you look
like a CBC you know you can't do that
you can't pull no one can pull that off
not even John Hamm can know I would have
try I was watching shark tank the day
before and it was a bunch of people that
you know seem passionate about their
businesses and ideas and then it was a
guy that as I did he was in a short suit
this is a day before all right you know
I know do a suit do shorts you're asking
people for money and you're wearing
shorts like you can't wear it it's like
it's like people wearing flip-flops to a
wedding you look come on now honestly I
mean open-toed shoes I I'm one of those
guys that just don't believe in open-toe
shoe by the man eh fine at the crib yeah
at a restaurant come on now just in a
wedding
come on stand on a plane pass no dogs in
restaurants either I don't care about
the dog friendly restaurants that's it I
think this is a weird policy it's a
beast to get it out of it well what
about the out the patio
patios fun because you know you're
already in nature yes
it's outside it's got birds out there
you're gonna cannot think of it the dog
haven't they usually don't
and they ain't licking plates and stuff
it's all right they crashed the wedding
yeah who crashed the wedding me and Edie
and Jacob it was one formal thing that I
opted out of I was like oh I don't know
about crashing the wedding we didn't
either man we were like you guys or it's
gonna be really funny and it thank God
because I think that popped up and
played tag no we kind of just walked
into the middle of their wedding and we
sent Renner in first if they're gonna
recognize anybody they're gonna it was
all I was black wedding by the way too
and we were like okay like you're going
in you're in the Avengers like
everybody's seen the Avengers like not a
huge black audience for new girl or Mad
Men or like it was real it was a real
kind of roll of the dice but they walked
in render kind of just walked in in like
a trance and then what walk to the the
glass door and like student in class to
her like who is this weirdo and someone
goes y'all that's Hawkeye and all the
phones came out it was like and they
started immediately freaking out and he
went up and grabbed the mic and did the
whole thing and then we all walked in
and it was ended up turning out really
nice but it was it was touch and go for
a while we did not know which way was
gonna go and they had all this elaborate
stuff planned out were like no we're
just walking and see if they recognize
doesn't if they don't we're gonna walk
how you guys kick it at all
whoo yeah just like hang out and no we
didn't we had it we had a full day of
press the next day and I think we were
like this is your way we don't really
want to like be doing this but [ __ ] if
you guys are that the my wedding I feel
like I only been in one wedding really
one wedding my sister's wedding in 2001
wait weren't you how much man for / Z I
do the bachelor party I didn't go to the
actual ceremony why is that a choice I
think I was working because where's
usually on
and I'm if you have your wedding on a
Tuesday I'm there Wednesday I'm there we
can stop it's tougher my my older
schedule where I toured you on the road
but now I can make a wedding I don't
really you know I'll tell you the truth
I don't like going with bunch of wedding
invitations from our listeners yeah yeah
they really do that's on certain pieces
of information I've been invited by
random people to weddings you know you
might enjoy going to weddings though no
I mean yeah if it's somebody that you
know or love or is in your life sure but
like the idea of going to somebody's
wedding you don't know like I get these
random invitations all the time I'm just
like I'm not what you don't want me it
before why would you want me in your
wedding is your bike the celebration of
cousin Jon Hamm yeah but still that's
weird
she'd do a speed wedding a group a group
on wedding and just and just pay for 10
10 different couples to get married do
10 weddings in an hour and a half that's
what that's 90 minutes so nine minutes
of wedding that's nice you have to go to
nine weddings at once and have a big and
then have a big party that's what I want
to do all right
this some of you heard it if you want to
get married email email us at the
handsome ramble at gmail.com and we'll
throw your wedding in a minute willing
it was constant dale's am I going
50,000 sorry yeah that's the catch you
have two thousand nine weddings you're
gonna get a half a million dollars out
of that Tony's retainer and you have to
show a receipt for your purchase of a
thousand tickets to see tagging
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
yeah that was fun
this is fun man I might have broken a
sweat doing that I'm not kidding that's
that's how that's how good a shape I'm
it just makes you feel is one that you
feel super musical you know it's true
you can follow a tone on it I had a
little period where I would just play
songs on my bluetooth speaker and then
I'll find the right pitch on it there
yeah and I feel like a real I was
feeling myself yep yeah it is
it's a it it's kind of an amazing
invention yeah we used to have these in
the green room just to prep for this I
did that for two shells and then I
realized I was being ridiculous no
parabens are gonna add up four of them
amazing
the and the original one it's like it
gets it's like a piece of furniture yeah
yeah it's tougher to play than that the
wood one you have actual skill uh-huh
this one you just got AB energy this
one's automated so it's like it's it
stays in the root right right in tune
right so it's like it's a easier it's
the easier one to you but if you get a
real theremin just to be able to play
the scale is it's a feat in itself
Wow yeah yeah we were talking about
Eugene Mirman used to do yeah it was
pretty good during the stand-up sets I
remember seeing him do it a few years
back so downtown
no no Acton no no hosting what are you
doing you building a cabinet where you
know what happened
[Laughter]
do you know Nick Offerman yeah he's a
great guy he's got that whole like would
work anything unlocked like it says oh
he really he's a real like a real
professional master carpenter and does
it for profit yeah yeah you can
Commission a table or Chester drawers or
cabinetry so you're trying to get into
that it wouldn't mind it I love used to
love playing with tools like all that
stuff was really fun to like mess around
with because it's you know yeah he's
feeling built something I don't have
have no skills in that whatsoever but I
do like going out and being active like
I live kind of close to Griffith Park so
I can take a 30-minute loop hike or I
can take a 50-minute hike right out my
front door which is really nice it just
makes you feel kind of good that's the
weather's always nice here so you kind
of feel lazy and shitty when you stay
inside all day so you exercise daily oh
if I don't I get pretty depressed yeah
really
yeah definitely orphan this guy's been
this doubles been on a kick
looking good cap working he's been doing
capital where one capoeira class well
what was what was the hardest part about
capoeira well it the class that I went
to it was just it was the teacher and it
was me
and one girl that might have been doing
it for a year or so uh-huh so he was you
know it was a lot of personal attention
but I I don't know I would rather been
maybe a couple other people write my
level right so kind of so you feel a
little more comfortable
yes so low just kind of working on I
wish there was somebody they've been
doing it a month or something to kind of
that's what scares me
that's what scares me about going to any
class like that yeah cuz I'm like it
will be my first time yeah there's
nothing that I have that level of skill
at and I will be terrible at it and if
you're with like a bunch of people that
are terrible you're like
we're terrible at this that's fine but
yeah the rest of it is that seems very
difficult to me it's is the little stuff
that I did was difficult but I've
learned to just I've been going to most
I had I've gone to the gym a couple
times all cycling group fitness cycling
boxing kickboxing a couple yoga classes
and I just accepted that I'm not good at
this some of these people are doing this
a few times a week I'm just doing this
I'm just but have you notice the thing
that like maybe the it's not the second
time but like the third time it's
radically easier oh with the cycling
cycling was destroying me the first
couple times and now I can actually do
it no I mean that's I started working
out after I finished this movie because
I was I was going crazy and I felt out
of shape and whatever and though the
first few times I did it I was like man
this is not for me you gotta get over
that hump yeah I can't do it and now
I've been I've been doing it pretty
solidly for like a few months and and
the stuff that I was doing the first
couple times I can I can get yeah
nothing and it's it's just you know just
teaching your body a new kind of new
normal yeah you train to fight you have
any kind of fighting no no not a big
fight you know you look like a tough guy
you look like you can fight from 47 I'm
wearing glasses I look like a tough guy
that's not my my thing no boxing no I've
been I've been in fights but I'm usually
the guy that said was that long arms
like whoa whoa everybody and that's and
of course that's the guy that gets hit
you ever get your ass kicked
yeah like what no but like I got I got
busted in the face when I was in college
doing that go ahead trying to be the
good fight someone came here came from
the side hit me in the face and bloodied
nose the whole thing it was it was it
was it was terrible I had to go back to
my girlfriend's house and her mom wasn't
and it was in the south so she's like
bless your heart
first time reading yeah bloody face
blood all over my white sweatshirt like
and she's like Oh bless your heart you
look oh you boys and she ran and got me
like a cold can of beer and like a bag
of frozen peas and just put the peas on
my face I was like drink this you'll
feel better I was like you are the best
mom in the world and she was very nice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah
[Music]
capoeira
caporals yeah trying trying to be
healthy trying to bring future yeah well
probably chance
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
damn John have you just snap John John
Jam that is for sure
tag June 15th June 15 take Peters
theaters nationwide theaters worldwide
well yeah it's gonna be all over various
dates Australia Australia China China I
probably won't be judging oh yeah but it
will be why Taiwan Taiwan definitely
yeah Taiwan Korea Europe Korea maybe
China's market is very specific well
John you still remain one of my heroes
thank you you wish the best for you and
good luck with the movie thank you thank
you so much this was gonna put us over
the top 100 million okay it was the last
piece of the trouble puzzle
[Music]
[Music]